je sais la non alors c'est david y
rendent complètement l'improviste juifs
encore vivante à gaza vivent case arriva
ouais tu sais quelle sauce je chante
assez drôle quand même
alors alors donc c'est david et rentre à
l'improviste chez lui il trouve sarah
allongé sur le lit à poil complètement
nue à cheryl sarah may mais pour
continuer comme ça en plein après midi
là sur lui ni comme ça qu'est ce qui se
passe à la caisse car tu vois bien que
malade
non non non non plus on voit bien
qu'elle est elle est emmerdé quoi a dit
non mais tu sais chérie tu m'achètes
plus de vêtements
alors moi je suis toute nue comment ça
je n'achète plus de vêtements et tout ce
que je passais tâche était bijoux les
voitures je tâchais plus de vêtements tu
te fous de moi sahara voici viens viens
viens voir bien voir verva il nous v'la
plat penderie comme ça il fait regardes
tu te fous de moi une robe de rome trois
bandes
cependant monsieur 4
[Applaudissements]
ce à la une et avec toujours dans des
abris
merci d'être là mon vieux père serge
mouchet très content de te voir ma
mission qu'on va se régaler avec toi ce
soir écouter et je vais commencer je
vois que ça t'a dit vas-y rapport
excusez moi ça va être un peu c'est un
ours polaire à north pole et un autre
voleur un autre polaire qui est avec son
petit fils en train de pêcher ni les lie
pêche et le petit papy way
car nous tolèrent toi dans les rayons il
va me et les ours polaires sur ta
m'habiller on se leurre et papa où il
saute on perd aussi et tous nos nerfs et
maman oui ça même aussi elle tombe
scolaire pour moi la belle chante
empêcher pourquoi tu me pose ces
questions parce que j'ai un peu froid
[Applaudissements]
alors ce soit elle va concourir aussi
pour intégrer la grosse rigolade c'est
au drake est avec nous ali mannequin
elle habite à paris merci audrey des
traverses et on peut dire moi c'est une
petite petite blague donc la différence
entre un meurtrier est un homme qui a
tué l'amour c'est quoi un meurtrier un
homme qui va me faire l'amour est
exactement c'est pas faut demander à
bouder sa pape a répondu schmaltz
j'habite à paris
[Rires]
alors en fait je vous explique qu'il n'a
aucune parce que chacun et cherche à
cacher les corps
[Applaudissements]
ricoh kétamine et quand les ferrures y
est amateur paris vase et rico en fait
c'est un monsieur à lunettes
en fait c'est un monsieur il habite dans
un village il est dans une grosse
société son patron bien le voir et lui
dit tu sais quoi paul été muté à new
york et lui c'est son qui vous allez à
new york
il prévient tout le village belle à new
york mon patron il m'a muté à new york
c'est magnifique paul c'est magnifique
new york au magnifique
alors il prépare ses bagages et tout ça
il en vaut il dit au revoir à sa femme
ilva l'aréoport commence à enregistrer
ses bagages et d'un coup il ya le patron
qui court derrière lui effet paul paul
vi il faut que je dise quelque chose
quoi qu'est-ce qui a tu vas plus à new
york au nom ne dit pas ça ne me dit plus
que la new york c'est plus possible
ouais mais j'ai prévenu tout le village
ma femme tout le monde pas possible
c'est une grande pour moi mais coûte
inquiète pas je sais ce que tu vas faire
tu vas rentrer chez toi il te fait que
mettre en dessous son lit et moi tu vas
me donner le double de décret je vais
rentrer chez toi et je veux donner de la
nourriture je vais te nourrir près j'ai
trouvé une solution t'inquiète pas au
bout de quatre jours on va trouver une
solution et on va essayer de trouver
pour que tu rentres chez toi et que on a
fait croire que tu es parti à new york
mais je veux manger en dessous le lit et
comment vers les toilettes t'inquiète
pas tu sais on souligne qu est ce que tu
te dis bon ok d'accord alors ils se
vendent sous le lit et tout ça le mec
qui vient le patron et lui donne de la
nourriture le liris nourrit comme un
chat et une mouche du failli me
retrouver tout ça
et d'un coup au bout du quatrième jour
il l'entend la porte de la chambre qui
ouvre sa femme est renté un étalon qui
arrivent les iphone dans le mais on y va
et on y va
il a des charmes au moins et il me fait
tout ce qu'ils font et d'atouts effet
tellement une position bizarre que la
femme est là la tête
en dessous le lit et elle voit le
ries et le marie lavoie effet je te jure
je rentre de new york de massacre
[Applaudissements]